I'll start with the small lab at men
with 450 pixels the only real change
from the default is that the light blue
and the green elements both take up
fifty percent of the viewport so at min
with 450 pixels I set with fifty percent
for the light blue and the green
elements so far so good admin with five
hundred and fifty pixels it looks like
the only difference is that now the red
box only takes up forty percent of the
viewport while the orange box takes up
sixty percent of the viewport so i made
my change in well to be honest this
doesn't quite look like what I expected
I thought the red box would be probably
a little bit farther over so you know
what let's go ahead and change something
inside devtools i'll change that forty
percent which I was mistaken about and
I'll change that to thirty three percent
which means that the width of the orange
box needs to be 66.6 percent I was a
little bold there and instead of testing
first I just went ahead and set the
widths inside my source code but looking
at the site this isn't actually what I
expected I think the orange isn't taking
up enough space and I think the red is
taking up too much space so i think i'll
use dev tools to make some adjustments
instead of 40 60 i'll go ahead and make
it one-third and two-thirds so red
becomes 33.3 percent and orange becomes
66.6 percent alright that's looking a
lot better and lastly there's min with
800 pixels the only difference between
550 and 800 pixels is that with 800
pixels that are now left and right
margins at the break point with a min
width of 800 pixels I went ahead and set
a fixed width of 800 pixels and then a
margin left and margin right of auto
with a quick save and a refresh of the
browser it looks like the page now has
margins on the left and right already
that looks pretty good